YEAH. I SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MEMBERS PLEASE ANSWER
BY SAYING PRESIDENT. RIGHT ALLEN. ALLEN PRESIDENT ARCHULETA
RIGHT ARCHULETA PRESENT ATKINS.
BATES BATES PRESENT BACKER RESIN
BAKER PRESENT FOR JUST. FOR JUST
PRESENT BRADFORD. BRADFORD
PRESENT CABALLERO. CORTES CORTEZ
THE PRESENT DALLY. DALLY PRESENT
DODD. DODD PRESENT DORADO
TORONTO PRESENT EGGMAN. EGGMAN.
PRESIDENT GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
PRESENT GROVE. GROVE PRESENT
HERTZBERG. WESO HER TADO. HER
TADO PRESENT JONES JONES PRESENT
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER PRESENT
LAYERED LAYARD PRESENT LEYVA
YOUR LEYVA PRESENT LIMÓN. AND
LIMÓN PRESENT MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
PRESENT MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
PRESENT MEN. MEN PRESENT NEWMAN
NEWMAN PRESENT NIELSEN NIELSEN
PRESENT BUT SHOW A VOGUE BUT
SHOW A VOTE PRESENT PAN. PAN
PRESENT PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO
PRESIDENT BARACK BROUGHT PRESENT
RUBIO I DIDN'T RUBIO PRESENT
SKINNER RIGHT SKINNER PRESENT
STERN. STERN PRESENT I'M BURKE
AMBERG PRESENT WHITE HOUSE SKI.
YOU WIENER. WIENER PRESENT WILK. YEAH QUORUM IS. EVERS WHAT
WELCOME YOU TO- TODAY'S HIS
FIRST AND HOPEFULLY ONLY A
SESSION IN THE SWING SPACE THIS
SESSION OBVIOUSLY LOOKS A BIT
DIFFERENT BECAUSE A BLOWN
TRANSFORMER IN DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO WHEN I THINK THE PRO
TEM'S OFFICE THE SECRETARY THE
SENATE AND THE SYSTEM SECRETARY
OF THE SENATE FOR THEIR WORK TO
GET TODAY'S SESSION UP AND
RUNNING. AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR FLEXIBILITY I WITH THAT
WITH OUR MEMBERS AND GUESTS
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER BY CENTER LAYERED AFTER
THAT PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR
THE PLEDGE BY CENTER STERN.
CREATOR GOD WE ASK YOU TO
ACCOMPANY US THIS DAY AS WE
STRIVE TO MAKE THE BEST POSSIBLE
DECISIONS FOR THE GOOD OF YOUR
PEOPLE. BE WITH US IN OUR TIMES
OF PHYSICAL NEED DISLOCATION AND
SPIRITUAL TRIAL WHEN WE ARE
TEMPTED TO FEAR AND DOUBT. IN
OUR QUEST FOR MORE JUST SOCIAL
ORDER WHEN WE ARE TEMPTED TO
DISCOURAGEMENT. BE WITH US IN
OUR ENCOUNTERS WITH THE POOR AND
NEEDY. OF OUR TIME WHEN WE ARE
TEMPTED TO GROW WEARY. IN OUR
DEBATES WITH PERSONS WHO
DISAGREE WITH US WHEN WE ARE
TEMPTED TO MISUNDERSTANDING. THE
WITH US IN OUR SUCCESS THIS IS A
GOVERNMENT'S BODY WHEN WE MAY BE
TEMPTED TO SELF SATISFACTION.
GRACIOUS AND MERCIFUL GOD
STRENGTHEN US ON THE JOURNEY OF
LEADERSHIP THAT WE MAY WITNESS
TO THE VALUE OF HUMBLE SERVICE.
FOR ALL THOSE WHO PUT THEIR
TRUST IN OUR WORK WE ASK THIS IN
YOUR NAME A MAN. MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
MOVING ON TO PRIVILEGES THE
FLOOR WE HAVE SOME RECOGNITIONS
AT TWO OUTSTANDING HIGH SCHOOL
ATHLETES WHO ARE HERE WITH US
THIS MORNING BOTH ATHLETES OF
THE YEAR. THEY ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR THE CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION- RYAN
OSBORNE FROM THE FALL RIVER HIGH
SCHOOL. WHO'S ALSO HEADED TO
HARVARD COLLEGE THIS FALL AND
CURE WILSON FROM KINGSBURG HIGH
SCHOOL HEADED TO A CORNELL THIS
FALL WITH EACH GIVE THEM GIVE
THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE. BY THE
SAN ALSO WAS THREE MARY SUE IN
THE THIRTY FIVE YEAR C. C. WHO
ARE HER THE CAPITOL. WELCOME TO
THE STATE SENATE. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
IT MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ COMMITTEE
REPORTS WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. NOW MOVING
ON TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION MEASURES
REPORTED FROM APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION TO PASS
WILL BE GIVEN THEIR SECOND
READING UPON BEING REPORTED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MEASURES
REPORTED FROM APPROPRIATIONS
WITH RECOMMENDATION TO PASS AS
AMENDED WILL BE GIVEN THEIR
SECOND READING. MATHIS ADAPTED
AND RETURNED TO SECOND READING.
CONSIDERATIONS THE DAILY FILE A
SECOND READING WILL BE DEEMED
READ. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO A
GOVERNMENT APPOINTMENTS- MISTER
LAYERED- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. FILE ITEM TEN CAROLINE
THOMAS JACOBS OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
CAROLINE THOMAS JACOBS AS THE
DIRECTOR OF OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY SHE
PREVIOUSLY WAS THE DIRECTOR OF
WILDLIFE SAFETY DIVISION AT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION SHE ALSO PREVIOUSLY
SERVED IN SEVERAL POSITIONS IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. SHE WAS
APPROVED IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MAY ELEVENTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. PHONE. K.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. S. C. NONE
MATT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ALLEN HI ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS. BATES BAKER
HI BAKER HI FOR JUST. BRADFORD
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO CABALLERO
HIGH COURT HAS HE OR HAS HE HI
DALLY. DALLY NO DODD ALL RIGHT
DODD HI TORONTO TORONTO HI
EGGMAN EGGMAN HI GLAZER GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH
GROVE NO HERTZBERG. WESO HER
TADO HER TADO HI JONES JONES NO
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER HI WHERE'D ALL
RIGHT LAYARD I LEYVA. LEYVA HI
LIMÓN HI LIMÓN HI MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO
MAN MAN HI NEWMAN. ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
BUT CHOI BOGUE A CHOI BOGUE NO
PAN ALL RIGHT PAN AYE PORTANTINO
. PORTANTINO AYE ROTH ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STERN AYE
NUMBER ALL RIGHT- BURKE I WHITE
HOUSE SKI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THE
BATES. BATES NO. PORTIS GORGEOUS. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG. WHEN
HUESO. WELL WILK. THESE ARE THE
ONES IN THE FIRM.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS OF THE RED
EYES ON FILE ITEM TEN. ALLEN
ARCHULETA BAKER BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTESE DODD TORONTO.
EGGMAN. GLAZER GONZALEZ HER TADO
KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA. OKAY
LIMÓN MCGUIRE MEN NEWMAN. PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER FOLLOWING MEMBERS HAVE
VOTED NO. BATES DALLY GROVE
JONES MELENDEZ NIELSEN A CHOI
BOGUE.
PRICE TWENTY EIGHT NO SEVEN THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED BUT
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ELEVEN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN. HE JOAQUIN
ESQUIVEL MEMBER WESTERN STATES
WATER COUNCIL. GRAYSON LET THANK
YOU FILE ITEM ELEVEN IS A
CONFIRMATION OF THE ROOM THE
JOAQUIN ESQUIVEL FOR APPOINTMENT
TO THE WESTERN STATES WATER
COUNCIL HE CURRENTLY SERVES AS
THE CHAIR OF THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MAY ELEVENTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF WALKING WALKING AS
WELL AS A MEMBER OF THE WESTERN
STATES WATER COUNCIL HE'S ALSO
ON THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD THE CHAIRMAN AND-
IT IT'S SURPRISING TO ME THAT HE
IS ONE OF THE ONLY MEMBERS THAT
REALLY UNDERSTANDS THAT 25% OF
THE WORLD'S FOOD SUPPLY COMES
FROM A CENTRAL VALLEY PHYSICALLY
FRESNO KERN AND TULARE COUNTIES
HE ALSO UNDERSTANDS THAT WE GROW
HUNDRED THIRTY COMMODITIES IN
THAT AREA. THAT CAN'T BE GROWN
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD AND
THERE'S NO BACK UP PLAN TO
REPLACE SAID IF WE CONTINUE TO
CUT OFF WATER TUR FARMERS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO I DO BELIEVE
THAT HE WILL- ADD VALUE- TO THE
NATION'S AND THE WORLD'S FOOD
SUPPLY BY BEING ON THIS WESTERN
STATE. WATER BOARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. C. NINE MEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS. BATES RIGHT BATES FIVE
BAKER ALL RIGHT BAKER HI FOR
JUST FOR JUST HI BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO CABALLERO
I CORTESE CORTESE HI DALLY. DODD
ALL RIGHT DODD HI TORONTO
TORONTO HI EGGMAN EGGMAN HI
GLAZER GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI GROVE GROVE HI
HERTZBERG. WESO HER TADO FURTADO
HI JONES. KAMLAGER KAMLAGER HI
LAYERED ALL RIGHT BLARED HI
LEYVA ALL RIGHT LEYVA HI LIMÓN.
LIMON HI MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ. MAN MAN HI NEWMAN
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. BUT CHAU
ABODE. A CHOI BOGUE HI PAM ALL
RIGHT PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH ROTH HI
RUBIO RUBIO HI SKINNER. SKINNER
AYE STERN ALL RIGHT STERN HI I'M
BURKE RIGHT AMBERG HI WHITE
HOUSE KING WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
DALLY DALLY. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
WEST OF WEST SEVERAL JONES JONES
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ. NIELSEN
NIELSEN WILK WILK. WITH. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS HAVE VOTED I'D
- ALLEN ARCHULETA. BATES BAKER
FORTUS BRADFORD CABALLERO CORTEZ
HE DODD RASO EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE APARTADO KAMLAGER
LAYERED ARE LEYVA LIMÓN MCGUIRE
. MEN NEWMAN A CHOI BOGUE PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG WHY CASKEY WIENER.
FIVE THREE TWO. THE EYES ARE
THIRTY TWO NOTES ARE ZERO THE
POINT IS CONFIRMED YET THANK YOU
OFF YOUR PATIENTS WERE TELLING
BY HAND SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE AS WE TALLY VOTES THAN
CONFIRM THEM- GIVEN THE
SITUATION BUT MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWELVE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. FILE ITEM TWELVE
KARLA NEMETH MEMBER WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL WHAT WATER
COUNCIL. THERE THERE THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT FILE ITEM TWELVE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF KARLA NEMETH
FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE WESTERN
STATES WATER COUNCIL SHE SERVES
AS DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES SHE WAS APPROVED
BY THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
MAY ELEVENTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIGHT FOOT. THANK YOU
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SIR NIELSEN. YEAH. THIS PRESENT
LADY GERMAN THE SENATE I DON'T
HAVE THE EXTENSIVE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH THE DIRECTOR NEMES
. SHE WAS PARTICULARLY HELPFUL
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WHEN THE
SPILLWAY FAILURE THAT ARE REAL
OCCURRED. AND HELPED US
NEGOTIATE THAT VERY DIFFICULT
DISASTROUS POTENTIAL SITUATION
COLLEGE THAN A GOOD JOB AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THAT DEPARTMENT AND
I SUPPORTER. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE. C. NONE
BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ALLEN HI ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS. BATES BATES
AYE BACKER AYE BECKER AYE FORTUS
PORGES HI BRADFORD. BRADFORD
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO CABALLERO
I CORTES E. CORTESE HI DALLI
DALLI HI DODD AYE DODD AYE
DORADO. RASO HI EGGMAN EGGMAN HI
GLAZER GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. GROVE HI
HERTZBERG. WESO HER TADO HER
TADO HI JONES OKAY JONES HI
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER HI BLARED.
WHERE'D HI LEYVA LEYVA HI LIMÓN
. LIMON HI MCGUIRE ALL RIGHT
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE MIN. MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NIELSEN HI PATROL BOGUE
. BUT CHOI BOGUE HI PAN ALL
RIGHT PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH ROTH IRA
RUBIO RIGHT RUBIO I SKINNER
RIGHT SKINNER AYE STERN. STERN
HI AMBERG. BOMBERG HI BY CASKEY
I'M QUITE HOUSEKI I WIENER
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS ARCHITECT
HERTZBERG HUESO WILL WILK THIRTY
SIX YEAR. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
VOTED I'VE ALLEN ARCHULETA BATES
BAKER FORTUS BRADFORD CABALLERO
QUARTET THE TALLY DODD ALSO
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALES GROVE HER
TADO JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED
LEYVA LIMÓN MCGUIRE MELENDEZ
MILLION NEWMAN NIELSEN ULTRA
BOGUE PAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG BY CASKEY
WIENER. THESE GUYS ARE THIRTY
SIX AT THE NOSE OR ZERO THE
POINT MEANT IS CONFIRMED THAT
MEMBERS NOW IS THE TIME TO
RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOW IT'S TIME
FOR JOURNAL MEMORIES LIKE TO
FIRST RECOGNIZE A CENTER MINUTES
CENTER BATES. OKAY. RIGHT SIR
BATES JUNE BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF LAGUNA GO
RESIDENT DONNA DR JOHN CHIANG HE
REVERED PHYSICIAN DEVOTED
HUSBAND AND FATHER AND HERO DR
CHIANG WHO PUT HIS LIFE IN
HARM'S WAY TO SAVE OTHERS AT THE
SCENE OF THE HORRIFIC ATTACK ON
THE PARISHIONERS OF THE
TAIWANESE PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH IN
LAGUNA WOODS HIS LIFE WAS
TRAGICALLY TAKEN AT THE YOUNG
AGE OF FIFTY TWO. ONE WITNESS
TOLD MEDIA REPORTS DR CHANG SAW
THE GUNMN AND IMMEDIATELY TOOK
ACTION TO TRY TO STOP HIM HIS
ACTIONS SAVED COUNTLESS LIVES
THAT DAY DR CHANG WAS A FAMILY
CARE AND SPORTS MEDICINE
PHYSICIAN INTO LISA VIEJO FOR
THE SOUTH COAST MEDICAL GROUP
AND MEDICAL GROUP HE HELPED CO
FOUND SEVERAL OF HIS PATIENTS
DESCRIBED HIM AS THE BEST
DOCTORS IN TOWN THE GENERAL
GENUINELY CARED ABOUT THE WELL
BEING OF HIS PATIENTS. HE WAS
BORN ON JUNE SIXTEENTH NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE AND GREW UP IN A
SMALL TOWN IN EAST TEXAS HE
ATTENDED TEXAS TECH TEXAS TEACH
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
AND COMPLETED HIS RESIDENCY AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES WHEN ASKED WHAT DROVE
HIM TO BECOME A PHYSICIAN DR
PROUDLY IT ANSWERED THAT IT WAS
THE RESPECT AND ADMIRATION HIS
HOMETOWN HAD FOR HIS FATHER WHO
IS ALSO A PHYSICIAN. EVEN THOUGH
HE WAS A FULL TIME POSITION DR
CHANG ALWAYS MANAGED TO GET BACK
TO HIS COMMUNITY HE DEEPLY CARED
ABOUT USE FORCE AND KEEPING
CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS ACTIVE
HIS PASSION. FOR SPORTS AS WELL
. BOTH HIM TO BECOME EIGHTEEN
PHYSICIAN FOR SEVERAL HIGH
SCHOOLS. HELLO POLICE GOING AGO
LOOK IN THE BEACH AND EL TORO
HIGH SCHOOL'S. ANDREW MASHBURN
THE ATHLETIC DIRECTOR FOR A
LEASE ON THE GO HIGH SCHOOL
DESCRIBED HIM AS AN AMAZING MAN
WHO IS KIND CARING AND HAPPY HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE AND
THEIR TWO CHILDREN. THE
RESIDENTS OF ORANGE COUNTY AND
I'D LIKE TO SAY OUR NATION OUR
NATION WILL BE FOREVER GRATEFUL
FOR DOCTOR CHANG'S KAROQ HERALD
HERO HERO KICK. SORRY I CAN'T
GET OUT OF GOT A LETTER IN MY
THROAT YOU CAN. HEROIC THANK.
AND I WAS SAY THAT. HE SAID.
FONG CERTAINLY ENTIRE- ENTIRE
CHURCH AND PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES
HAVE BEEN TAKEN FAMILIES
DESTROYED AND SO THE NATION THE
NATION. WILL BE FOREVER GRATEFUL
FOR HIS ROLE WITH SACRIFICE I
ASKED WE TURN IN THE MEMORY OF
DR JOHN CHIANG THANK YOU. 50% OF
MEN. THIS. MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY AS WELL
THAT- JOINS CENTER BATES AND
TURNING IN THE MEMORY OF DR JOHN
CHIANG. ON THE AFTERNOON OF
SUNDAY MAY FIFTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO AROUND ONE
THIRTY PM A TRAGIC MASS
SHOOTING. WITHIN A HOUSE OF
WORSHIP OCCURRED IN LAGUNA
WOODS. SOMETHING THAT HAS
SHOCKED ARE ORANGE COUNTY IN
ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES.
WHILE CELEBRATING THE OVERSEAS
RETURN OF THEIR FORMER PASTOR
CONGREGANTS OF THE TAIWANESE
PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH GATHERED AT
GENEVA PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH IN
LAGUNA WOODS. FOR WHAT WAS
EXPECTED TO BE AN AFTERNOON
LUNCHEON OF HAPPINESS HOPE AND
FAITH. AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
UNFAMILIAR WITH LAGUNA WOODS
IT'S A SMALL SLEEPY RETIREMENT
COMMUNITY- EVERYONE KNOWS EACH
OTHER- THE IDEA THAT SOMETHING
LIKE THIS WOULD HAPPEN IN A
HOUSE OF WORSHIP IN A CHURCH. IN
LAGUNA WOODS I THINK- IS
TERRIFYING AND ANYTHING TO DO
SOMETHING THAT HAS REALLY
SHOCKED OUR COMMUNITIES- IF IT
CAN HAPPEN IN LAGUNA WOODS IT
CAN AND WILL HAPPEN AS WE'VE
SEEN IN ANYWHERE- AND THE
SPECTER OF GUN VIOLENCE OF HATE
IS SOMETHING THAT- I KNOW IT'S
JUST BEEN- IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
AS REALLY DISTURB SO MANY
MEMBERS. OF OUR COMMUNITY. WHAT
UNFOLDED NEXT WAS ABSOLUTELY
HEARTBREAKING A LONE WOLF
EXTREMIST INFILTRATORS
CELEBRATION- BEGAN FIRING INTO
THE CROWD OF ELDERLY PRISONERS.
BY ACTING QUICKLY DR CHANG DID
NOT TRY TO RUN OR TAKE COVER HE
SPRUNG TO ACTION AS OTHERS IN
THE ROOM TOOK FIRE. OR SEARCH
FOR COVER DR CHANG CHARGES THE
SHOOTER TRYING TO DISARM HIM AND
IN THE ENSUING SCUFFLE. AS THIS
SEQUENCE GUN JAMMED- DR CHANG
WAS ABLE TO HELP TAKE HIM DOWN
ALTHOUGH HE WAS MORTALLY WOUNDED
IN THE PROCESS. NOW THIS GUNMAN
HAD CHAINED THE DOORS SUPER
GLUED THE LOCKS AND HATED
MOLOTOV COCKTAILS THROUGHOUT
THIS SO SOCIAL HALL. HIT
METICULOUSLY WORKED OUT A SCHEME
TO INFLICT THE MOST DAMAGE
POSSIBLE AND EXECUTE AS MANY
PEOPLE AS HE COULD. WITNESSES
SAY THAT WAS BECAUSE OF JOHN'S
BRAVERY HIS ACT OF COURAGE THAT
THE FELLOW ATTENDEES COULD TAKE
CONTROL AND SUBDUE THE SHOOTER.
WHEN I'M COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT ARRIVED THEY FOUND
THE SHOOTER HOGTIED WITH
ELECTRICAL WIRES. AND DISARMED
AND IT WAS DUE TO DOCTOR JOHN
CHANG'S BRAVERY WHO SACRIFICED
HIS ACTIVE OF UNSELFISHNESS-
THAT HE THE SHOOTER WAS TAKEN
DOWN AND- THIS WAS INDICATIVE OF
WHO JOHN CHIANG WAS- THIS MAN
WAS A DOCTOR. A HEALER AMANTS
OKAY STERN WITH SAFEGUARDING THE
- IN WELL BEING OF A- THAT. HE
REACT. WAS AGAIN NOT TO COVER TO
SELFLESS- SO THAT OTHERS CAN
LIVE- HUSBAND FATHER AND PILLAR
OF OUR ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
DR JOHN CHIANG GREW UP IN A
SMALL TOWN IN TEXAS. WHERE IT'S
FATHER HAD A SMALL MEDICAL
PRACTICE HE FOLLOWED IN HIS
FATHER'S FOOTSTEPS. AND AFTER
GRADUATING FROM MEDICAL SCHOOL
AT TEXAS TECH UNIVERSITY
MEDICINE ESTABLISHED HIS FAMILY
AND SPORTS MEDICINE PRACTICE AND
WE SHOULD BE A CO. HE ALSO
VOLUNTEERED AS A TEAM FROM THE
POSITION FOR LEASE AND GAIL EL
TORRO AND LAGUNA BEACH HIGH
SCHOOLS. HE HIS LIFE WAS AN
EXAMPLE OF SERVICE TO OTHERS AT
FIFTY TWO YEARS OLD- THIS
MARTIAL ARTS ENTHUSIASTS WAS A
SEVEN STAR PRAYING MANTIS
GRANDMASTER AT THE TOP OF HIS
MEDICAL CAREER. WE CONTINUE TO
HEAR STORY AFTER STORY FROM HIS
PATIENTS AND COLLEAGUES ABOUT
HIS KINDNESS WARMTH AND
DEDICATION TO CARING FOR AND
PROTECTING THOSE AROUND HIM. AS
WE KNOW FROM ALL THOSE WHO KNEW
AND LOVED HIM BEST DOCTOR JOHN
CHIANG WAS A TRUE ROLE MODEL.
AND EXAMPLE TO HOW OF HOW TO
LEAD IN THE SERVICE OF OTHERS. I
DON'T ESTIMATED THIRTY TO FORTY
PEOPLE IN THAT PRESSURES HALL
WITH DOCTOR JOHN CHIANG. NO
DOUBT HIS ACTIONS SAVED THE
LIVES OF DOZENS OF PEOPLE. AND
THE COMMUNITIES OF LAGUNA WOODS
ORANGE COUNTY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL ALWAYS BE
GRATEFUL AND HUMBLED FOR HIS
FEARLESSNESS VALOR AND
SACRIFICE. HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS
BELOVED WIFE AND TWO TEENAGE
DAUGHTERS. AMERISPEC WE ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. AND
OFFER OUR MOST SINCERE
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY HIS
COLLEAGUES AS WEAPONS. TOUCH A
PEN. I THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATOR SITS YOU WISH
TO RETURN MEMORY OF DR JOHN
CHIANG AS A CHILD OF TAIWANESE
IMMIGRANTS IN A POSITION- DR
CHANG CERTAINLY SAMPLE OF
SOMEONE WHO HIS BRAVERY- OF
COURSE NOT ONLY FIRST OF THE
POSITION HE WAS WELL KNOWN IN
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY AND SO IN
CALIFORNIA AS SOMEONE WHO WAS A
MENTOR SOMEONE WHO IS A VERY
IMPORTANT LEADER- THIS IS AN
EXISTING AN EXAMPLE FOR THE
TAIWANESE COMMUNITY THIS EVENT
CERTAINLY HAS SHAKEN THE
TAIWANESE COMMUNITY AND SO AND
CALIFORNIANS HERE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THE IS THAT THE
VIOLENCE OF THE EVENT BUT DR
CHANG NOT ONLY OF COURSE SAVE
LIVES IS A PHYSICIAN AND- HE
WAS- WILL RECOGNIZE AND ALSO
ISN'T SOMEONE WHO MENTORED YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY OF
COURSE. SACRIFICES OWN LIFE TO
SAVE OTHERS- I THERE'S NOT NOT
MUCH TO ADD TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID BUT I DO
WANNA MAKE NOTE THAT- YEAH WE
SAW OVER THE WEEKEND INCLUDING
THIS INCIDENT WHICH IS TAKEN THE
TOWNIES COMMUNITY- EXTREMISM AND
VIOLENCE COMING TOGETHER. AND I
THINK RECENTLY THE PRESTIGIOUS
REPORTED THAT- BLAKE THE
INCIDENT BUFFALO OF THE- THE
PERPETRATOR OF THIS INCIDENT
AND- IN ORANGE COUNTY AT THE
CHURCH. THAT THE PERPETRATOR
ALSO PUT OUT A MANIFESTO-
THROUGH- THE INTENDED MAILED IT
TO THE PRESS AND SO FORTH- WE-
NEED TO STOP EXTREMISM AND
VIOLENCE HERE IN OUR COUNTRY. DR
CHANGE GAVE HIS LIFE TO PROTECT
OTHERS WE DO NOT NEED MORE LIVES
LOST EXTREMISM. SO AGAIN I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF DR
CHANGE AND FOLLOW EXAMPLE AND
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT EXTREMISM
AND EXTREMISM AND VIOLENCE IN
OUR COUNTRY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND- COULD YOU PLEASE BE SURE TO
BRING HIS NAME UP SO WE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. IT NOW
TURN TO CENTER BRADFORD. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I STAND HERE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF AN
INNOCENT INDIVIDUALS NONE OF
WHOM ARE RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
NOT A CONSTITUENT OF MINE BUT
WORTHY OF THIS RECOGNITION AND
WORTHY OF THE GERMAN. I REALLY
STRUGGLE HERE TODAY BUT THIS
GERMAN. I STRUGGLE IT HOW WE
HONOR TEN INNOCENT BLACK
AMERICANS WHO WERE BRUTALLY
GUNNED DOWN ASSEMBLY GROCERY
SHOPPING. BY WHITE SUPREMACIST
RACIST CALLER IN BUFFALO NEW
YORK ON MAY FOURTEENTH THIS
PROSPERITY THE MURDER WILL NOT
BE NAMED HERE TODAY. I WILL NOT
QUOTE FROM HIS MANIFESTO ARE ANY
OF THE DETAILS OF HIS MENTAL
STATE. NONE OF THAT REALLY
MATTERS. WHAT MATTERS IS THE
LIVES THAT WERE LOST THAT DAY.
INNOCENT MEN. WOMEN WHO WERE
SIMPLY OUT SHOPPING. HONESTLY
I'M TIRED. AND IN THE WORDS OF
FANNIE LOU HAMER I'M SICK AND
TIRED OF BEING SICK AND TIRED.
WE'RE TIRED OF ALL OF US ON
THIS. ON THIS FLOOR SHOULD BE
TIRED AS WELL. AND IF YOU'RE NOT
TIRED. INDUCE SOME SELF
REFLECTION ON WHY THE LOSS OF
THESE LIFE DO NOT IMPACT YOU.
WHY YOU HAVEN'T LOST SLEEP OR
SHED A TEAR. I'M PART OF THE
EXCUSES I'M TIRED OF THEIR
JOURNEY IN A MEMORY FOR REGULAR
BLACK AMERICANS LOSING THEIR
LIVES TO VIOLENCE RACIAL BIGOTS
FOR JUST BEING BLACK IN AMERICA.
I'M TIRED OF HOUSE TAX AFTER
HAVE STACKS NAMES THAT HAVE BEEN
LOST I'M TIRED OF SEEING ALLY
SIMPLY TWEET ABOUT INJUSTICES
INJUSTICES WITHOUT TAKING REAL
ACTION. BLACK AMERICANS CANNOT
GO JOGGING AHMAD OPERATE IN
GEORGIA. CANNOT PLAN A PARK. TO
MERE RICE IN CLEVELAND. OUR
BORDER CHURCH SENATOR CLEMENTE
ME AND EIGHT OTHERS. AT MOTHER
EMANUEL CHURCH IN SOUTH CAROLINA
WITHOUT A REAL THREAT OF
VIOLENCE. EVERY DAY AND EVERY
ACTION WE MUST THINK ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL THREATS OF OUR LIVES
AND BODIES SIMPLY BECAUSE OF OUR
CALLER. I'M SURE SOME OF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR QUOTES FROM
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING TODAY.
SOME WOULD PROBABLY WANT ME TO
HEALING AND THERE WILL BE TRULY
TIME FOR THAT. BUT TODAY. WE ARE
AN INFURIATED TODAY WE CANNOT
SPEAK TO THE HEALING WHEN WE DO
NOT SPEAK TO THE ROOT CAUSE AND
THAT'S RACISM RACISM IS VIOLENCE
IN THIS COUNTRY TODAY ON THE
BIRTHDAY I'M CHANNELING.
MALCOLMX ON HIS BIRTHDAY I
SHOULD TO. CONCERNING
NONVIOLENCE IT'S CRIMINAL TO
TEACH A MAN NOT TO DEFEND
HIMSELF WHEN HE IS IN CONSTANT
IT IS A CONSTANT VICTIM OF
BRUTAL ATTACKS COLLEAGUES. HOW
LONG SHALL WE TOLERATE THIS
VIOLENCE TOWARDS THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. HOW CAN'T WOUNDS HEAL
WHEN WE KEEP GETTING INJURED HOW
LONG CAN WE AS A NATION CONTINUE
TO KID OURSELVES HERE. THIS
COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED ON RACISM.
IT IS THE BEDROCK- THIS NATION
IS AND WHO WE ARE AS A NATION.
OUR ENTIRE ECONOMY IT WAS
CREATED ON THE BACKS OF BLACK
SLAVES. AND HERE WE ARE TODAY.
STILL BEING HUNTED DOWN BY OUR
ANCESTORS. SOMEONE HELP ME
UNDERSTAND. THE ALLIES OF THE
BLACK COMMUNITY. IT IS YOUR TIME
IT IS YOUR TIME TO STOP
PARTICIPATING IN RALLIES CREATED
BY AND FOR BLACK AMERICANS IT'S
TIME FOR YOU TO CREATE YOUR OWN
RALLIES IN YOUR OWN COMMUNITIES
IN YOUR OWN NEIGHBORHOOD THE
ADVOCATE THE END OF RACISM IN
THIS COUNTRY. IT IS TIME FOR YOU
TO STOP ROLLING YOUR EYES WHEN A
FAMILY MEMBER SAYS SOMETHING
RACIST IT'S TIME TO ACT. IT IS
TIME TO STOP IGNORING YOUR
FRIEND FROM ELEMENTARY SCHOOL-
WHO POST SOMETHING ON FACEBOOK.
IT IS TIME TO ACT. YOU CANNOT
CALL YOURSELF A REAL ALLY UNLESS
THERE'S ACTION. WE'RE WATCHING.
TO MY COLLEAGUES EVEN THOSE ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE SOME
WHO CLAIM THERE'S NO RACISM IN
AMERICA ANY LONGER IT'S TIME TO
WAKE UP IT'S TIME TO OPEN YOUR
EYES MALCOLM ACT STATED. IT'S
TIME FOR YOU. YOU ARE NOT TO BE
SO BLIND BY TO PATRIOTISM THAT
YOU CANNOT FACE. REALITY WRONG
IS WRONG NO MATTER WHO DOES IT
OR WHO SAYS. WE ARE TIRED
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OR THE LUXURY TO DO
NOTHING. I ASKED FOR SILENCE AND
REFLECTION AS I READ THE NAMES
OF THOSE MURDERED. RUTH WHAT
PHIL EIGHTY SIX REQUIRE MEMBER
IN OUR CHURCH. PEARL YOUNG
SEVENTY SEVEN A RETIRED TEACHER
CATHERINE MASSEY SEVENTY TWO THE
RETIRED BLUESHIELD WORKER AND A
BLOCK CLUB PRESIDENT HEY WE'RE
PATTERSON A DEACON IN HIS CHURCH
CELESTIN CHENEY'S SIXTY FIVE A
MOTHER A GRANDMOTHER AND A
CANCER SURVIVOR. ERODING TALLY
SIXTY TWO I MOTHER AARON SALTER
FIFTY FIVE A RETIRED POLICE
OFFICER WORKING AS A SECURITY
GUARD AT TOP MARKET. ANDRE
MAGNERO THE FATHER WHO WAS
SIMPLY BUYING A BIRTHDAY CAKE
FOR HIS SON. MARGUS MORRISON
FIFTY TWO A RETIRED SECURITY
GUARD AND BUT STATE AMBER BURDA.
JURY THIRTY TWO A DAUGHTER. ANY
TIME I HOPE YOU HAD OPPORTUNITY
TO REFLECT ON BEING ANTI RACIST
DID YOU THINK ABOUT HOW OUR
BEHAVIOR FEDERAL LACK THERE UP
IMPACTS OTHERS WHO DO NOT LOOK
LIKE YOU. DID YOU THINK ABOUT
THE PEOPLE IN YOUR LIFE WHO YOU
NEED TO REACH OUT TO. AND
CLOSING MY FINAL QUOTE FROM
APPLE MACS. WE DECLARE OUR RIGHT
ON THIS EARTH TO BE A HUMAN
BEING. TO BE RESPECTED AS A
HUMAN BEING TO BE GIVEN THE
RIGHTS OF A HUMAN BEING AND THE
SOCIETY. ON THIS EARTH IN THIS
DAY WHICH WE INTEND TO BRING
INTO EXISTENCE BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY. I SENT COMFORT AND
LOVE TO THE FAMILIES TOUCHED BY
THIS GRISLY CARLY ACT. WE WILL
MOURN YOU BUT WE WILL NEVER
FORGET YOU GOD BLESS YOU BUT
HOPEFULLY ONE DAY GOD BLESS
AMERICA I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
THE NAMES IN THE MEMORY OF THE
TEN LOST IN BUFFALO NEW YORK.
THANK YOU CENTER EVER PLEASE
BRING THOSE NAMES UP SO THEY CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. RIGHT
NOW WE MOVE ON TO- COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SERVICE CENTER
PORTANTINO. IF SOMETHING
HAPPENED TO THE OF. WELL OKAY
THE- PROCREATION COMMITTEE WILL
MEET AT ELEVEN ON AT ELEVEN
O'CLOCK IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. HEY GIVE ME CENTER DOT
. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THE G.
O. COMMITTEE WILL BEAT IN ONE
HALF AN HOUR IN THIS ROOM. I
CENTER EGGMAN. BUDGET SUB THREE
WILL MEET IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED. TWENTY MINUTES FROM
CONCLUSION OF THE SESSION.
THIRTY IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS CENTER BATES YES IT'S
CLEAR. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
BEING SO ACCOMMODATING WITH
TODAY'S SESSION OR NEXT SESSION
WILL BE MONDAY MAY TWENTY THIRD
AT TWO PM. THE SEATTLE BE
RECESSED INTO A LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS RECEIVED AT THE DESK AT
WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE PLACED THANK YOU.